this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happened you bad
[__] it's Monday the 17th of
the month and in honor of 4 20. Uncle
Joey's joint is brought to you by freeze
pipe the best Bonds in the [__]
Market how do I know because I've been
smoking since I've been in [__]
diapers get ready to smoke without
throat burn for the coldest smoothest
[__] smoking experience you've ever
had get a freezable pipe bubbler or bung
from the freeze pipe the secret is this
it's the glycerin chamber pop that baby
in the freezer for an hour and watch as
you smoke is cooled by 300 degrees
listen guys you know me dog I love my
little buns and when it comes to freeze
pipe whether it's the bubbler whether
it's the bung whether it's the pipe and
now the tornado which is [__]
tremendous 420 is here and freeze pipe
biggest sale of the year is about to end
that's right it's the Cannabis Christmas
and you can save up to 40 on select
pipes bubblies of bongs and more visit
freezepipe.com and find your new
favorite piece use something like that's
not on sale use code Diaz and save 10 on
your entire order again that's
freezepipe.com use code Diaz for 10 off
your entire order or shop the 420 sale
guys enjoy and smoke yourself until it
comes out of your [__] ears you
understand me the joint is also brought
to you by bam liquid IV listen Festival
season is coming up for you Young Bucks
after days of booze in the desert stinky
feet and Weirdos breathing on you you're
gonna need to refuel liquid IV has you
covered just one stick and you're gonna
get five essential vitamin and it
hydrates you quicker than water alone
two times faster than one alone and even
has three times the electrical lights of
traditional sports drinks and it comes
in 12 delicious flavors like sea Berry
oh my God strawberry lemonade tremendous
pina colada [__] blow your wig off
and you know me concord grape I'm still
slinging dick like Uncle Joey that's my
personal favorite is the concord grape
and the [__] Sherry and the tropical
punch oh my God liquid IV has five
essential vitamins you need to feel you
best B3 B5 B6 B12 and vitamin C it's
also non-GMO non-gluten Dairy and soy
free so do me a favor you could grab
your liquid IV and bulk it nationwide at
Costco well guess what you get 20 off
when you hang out with your Uncle Joey
so go to liquid iv.com use code Joey and
check out j-o-e-y that's 20 off anything
you order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code Joey at liquid
iv.com all right I got liquid IV and I
got uh whatever the [__] it's time to
sling some dick let's get this podcast
started
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
joint
[Music]
foreign
what's happening You Beautiful Savages
it's Monday the 17th of April
unbelievable we got a great week coming
up we got 4 20 the celebration of
[__] potheads so Thursday we'll be
we're walking around like [__] Dawn
of the Dead Or Jack the [__] up playing
paying a hundred dollars per joint in
New York City but it's good it's fun
hopefully we'll have some great weather
and that's it uh we got a whole new week
with a whole new [__] set of rules
it's a Monday motivation this Monday
ready for this we got a [__] guess
the author of tremendous Miss Erica
[__] Florentine thank you for
coming on
thank you so much for having me I'm so
excited I'm happy that you're here and
stuff I wanted just to ask you some
questions to give people we wrote a book
together I talked she wrote it and put
it together she's the real Mastermind
behind the book
uh we released it May 2nd you know we've
been working on it for two [__] years
before I met you I was making notes for
10 years didn't know what to do
and it was just the uh perfect
collaboration you know it's funny just
to let you know this was a very hard
book to write
because it just wasn't one element there
was so many elements of this book
there's a just to let you guys know
about La how I tell people that they
don't know dick about dick
I was stuck for years trying to write
this book and there's a lady who
advertises huge huge in the writing
community in LA
righteous she spends tons of money on
Advertising her goal is to help me
finish writing your book
she charges you this much and if you
work with it I'm very reasonable I
finally contacted her
like about a year before I came here I
was stuck and she was mutual friends
with uh acting coach Evanna Chubbuck
they had a lot of programs working
through her school
so I contacted her metaphor lunch you
know
she showed up like with [__] three
assistants you know
yeah I mean it was guys it was want the
whole coffee the other one to hold the
dog and the other one to hold the phone
and listen I wish I was exaggerating I
wish I was [__] lying to you people
it was like sit with her meanwhile she'd
had to be dipping the scales of 400. she
had like a donut a crumb bun and a
[__] Starbucks that looked like a
[__] public ice cream
and three assistants and she was talking
to me and then going uh hold on send
Johnny a text and send Johnny Depp a
text I'll meet him for lunch on Thursday
and then Amelia watching with FiFi you
know
the coffee I don't understand put some
more it was it was [__] I thought I
was getting put on like I thought and it
was like 500 for the [__]
consultation like just to meet where it
was 500 bucks for this [__] you know
women mole and you're like what the [__]
and she read I spoke to her she called
me a week later she goes
after my discussion with my colleagues
you either have to pick this
you have to pick a subject here we
cannot do the criminality and the comedy
and the cocaine the kidnapping it would
not work you know yeah and I was like
okay thank you for your time and then
she tried to give me an ear beating like
you know if you wanted to work I'd have
to refer you to myself it would have to
be like a three-woman project and I
would need nine assistants you know for
one test to sharpen my pencil I mean it
was [__] comical
I still see this lady putting ads on him
I just I'm telling you this because I
want you to really understand what you
did I still see this lady putting ads up
I still get emails from her come to my
workshop how to write a book in three
days you know what I'm saying
scam it's a [__] that just to let you
know I went through
you know I was first I signed with an
agent out of New York
and it was you ain't gonna believe this
[__] guys because we don't you know it's
like I tell Mike some stories sometimes
like how come I didn't know that because
Mike I was going through so much at the
time
I never had time to tell people how hard
it was to put this book together
first I had a guy that was a consultant
he oh he was
this guy didn't even write with a pet he
still had a feather you know he wrote I
thought this guy wrote everything he
wrote the Declaration of Independence he
wrote Every I mean if you listen to him
you know he helped this guy with the
script you know
it was a [__] nightmare nobody he
would tell me nobody wants to hear about
the criminal
um nobody wants to hear about the
cocaine nobody I mean it was [__] sad
I had that guy and he would rewrite all
my [__] and send it back to me and it
sounded like my book was getting written
by Robin Hood like I went to the Valley
of the darkness there was no darkness in
Jersey [__]
you guys just have no idea this went on
and on
then I got a book agent that was going
to put me with two writers
those two writers were God awful one guy
showed up with flip-flops he was picking
his toes while he was talking to me on
43rd Street and eighth one time at a
coffee shop picking his toes with the
[__] pen
okay I don't know and he was like
sniffing it and then he would go deep in
his toe even I don't do that [__] in
public in public I do it in private
no no so then I have a comedy showcase
and he goes I want to bring the book
office to the comedy showcase at the
stand this is the old stand yeah
Erica
he comes in looking like you did today
beautiful
and within minutes he looks like Uncle
Dan
he's disheveled he's got two beers he's
talking about the next covering I'm like
what are you talking about the next
thing you know I try to get him out of
the comedy club and he goes let's go
next door to a bar I know these people
he goes next door to he has to bartender
for a drink you can tell them he annoyed
the people there the bartender just
turned his head and went the other way
you know what this [__] did
he went behind the bar and started
making his own coffee now like broke out
in this bar and here I am by the stand I
have no idea where I am and there's a
fight in this [__] bar because the
guy I walked in there with decided to go
behind the bar and make his own [__]
drink then they called The Stand and
they said [__] about me which even the
people were like he didn't do anything
he would I wasn't even drinking I don't
even drink that was what I went through
it was constant
it was constant that I had people who
would just contact me like the podcast
go I'm a writer and I live in San Diego
I had a girl who was committed I'm doing
this disappeared
like crazy disappeared then I had
another girl who was tall went to uh
what's the big school they all go to in
L.A at CSU what is it uh USC USC yeah
yeah USC I was a valedictorian you know
yeah I created the Kardashians yeah oh
my God
she wanted me to write the book but
doing one-man shows so every week I
would have to go on stage at the [__]
at the something theater
right next to a weed store I still get
emails from this loser theater they do
like Halloween shows all year round the
guy's like a ghoul Fest like he's into
yeah
I'm sorry I'm [__] taken from your
time Erica but I just wanted to show you
how valuable you were to me I appreciate
that I mean I think the thing is a lot
of people say that they're writers
and a lot of people unfortunately are
not writers now I'm not saying I'm the
best in the world right everyone has
lots of things to learn still but I have
come across so many people who tell me
their
an expert writer and they've done all
these sorts of things and then you have
them do a two-pager to give you a sense
of what their style is and it's it's not
writing I think it's you know what it is
it's like
um I would say right around the time I
was graduating college probably like
2009 time frame blogs became so big so
anyone with a keyboard could be a writer
right and if you had some sort of degree
that matched could match but that you
didn't necessarily have to have a
journalism degree you can have some sort
of communications degree in general or
maybe even not and you can just Market
yourself as a writer and uh you know
it's also funny too I'm thinking of all
these people who claim that they can
write these books I've seen so now I've
been ghost writing books for a few years
and if you do a Google search people
will say oh I'll write your book for
five hundred dollars how are you gonna
write somebody's book for 500 that's not
a quality piece of work that you're
going to get for but yeah they just
Market themselves that way and then
upsell you on things that have nothing
to do with writing it's a it's a whole
thing at the end of the day I always
think if someone's trying especially to
pull a memoir together they're important
life stories you have to work with
somebody who is on the same train of
thought as you who's not going to guide
you away from don't tell your criminal
stories those are part of yours you know
somebody telling you not to tell that is
silly they don't know your audience your
people love your criminal store I mean
come on and also I've shared bits and
pieces just within my closed Circle
people that aren't familiar with some of
your criminal stories or other things in
your past that have read it and they're
like I cannot wait to read the rest of
how this is going to play out I told
some of my friends I'm like you know
there's one chapter it's called the
kidnapping they're like what do you mean
we can't wait to see what the kidnapping
is about you know like people are living
for this and uh you know anyone who
would guide you away from telling
important stories are just silly I don't
know I mean I just I was Nelly looking
right now I live conflicted because I
have all this commonly knowledge you
know and I love to sit with people
and help them but the problem is you
have
I have to decipher and it's very hard to
tell somebody this it's very hard to
charge somebody money for this when you
pass on this type of stuff you're doing
it as a labor of love and
there's all too much of that now like
that people are inexperienced there's
too much of that New York there's too
much of that anywhere where people are
inexperienced they teach workshops or
something like that yeah and it
frustrates you as
because the most frustrating thing is to
want help you don't want somebody to do
it for me Eric I don't want somebody to
do it for me I just need guidance and
help and and you're not going to find
that a lot of time you're not going to
find quality guidance and I know from
stand up which stand up I went through
20 agents and then I've realized guess
who the best agent was of me so I would
hustle rolls you know based on people oh
joy I went for this audition they're
looking for you at this audition I won't
even tell my agent I would just do it on
my own you know yeah because it's a
waste of time but what I'm trying to get
to is it's so weird when people are
looking to do something
the quickest path is to just do it
themselves until and that opens up those
doors I enjoyed the blogging when the
blogging first came out that opened my
that was the first storytelling I had on
MySpace I would do the Monday morning
blog way before podcast came up you got
to find them the first five of them were
god-awful
because I had never written like the
only thing I had ever written was I'm
driving down the road and also I think
about a joke and you write on a piece of
napkin like keywords and the jokes you
remember it but I hadn't written
longhand you know like the whole thing
oh my God I don't know like two of them
though and people were like Joe you got
to go back to school your pronunciation
you're not stopping too many commas it
was god-awful it's a process you're just
not gonna get up off the boat and
[__] write and I realized honest to
God whatever Advance they gave us for
this book I already spent mine I already
gave it to Jean perray and all those
other writers that wrote how to write
books I would spend my I gave Samuel
French sixty thousand dollars easy over
the years with comedy books and comedy
writing books and how to write and how
to write comedy and and the thing is if
you're going to write a book
and try to sell it
at least I would write the book I would
buy the book 25 bucks read two chapters
but I would miss what they were saying
to write you have to write every day
that's it yeah yeah that's it you're not
gonna learn how to write it's like Jiu
Jitsu you can watch all the
instructional videos you want eventually
you're gonna have to get on your back
and start [__] wrestling
[__] yeah and it's the same
thing with writing and I didn't know I
would write comedies thinking I'm doing
what Gene perett told me and all these
other great writers if you're not
writing writing is the you don't even
need a book you don't even need to buy
Jean Perez book or
uh Erica florentine's book on how to
write you don't need to if you write
every day you get a [__] notebook and
just go I'm gonna write a page every
goddamn day in five years you'll become
a great writer just all the it's all
pointed at you I fully agree with you I
always say when people come to me and
say you know I really want to learn how
to write on my own
um and I I want you to give me the
guidance but I don't want you to
actually do the content for me just help
give me any advice you have and I always
start with that just write just even if
it makes no sense just put pen to paper
or type it or whatever you want to do
with it just write around and write and
do it every single day and I'll I'll be
honest I still I've been writing my
entire career and I still take writer's
workshops I'm doing one currently I just
because it's helpful to continue to
write every single day and then also get
people's feedback like I'm always doing
those sorts of things unrelated to my
projects because it helps it really
really helps so only way that you're
going to be able to
start making any sort of progress but I
agree there's tons and tons of
information out there how to be a writer
and uh you'll spend the million dollars
in books how to be a comic how to be
musician how to be a guitarist how to
draw yeah you'll drop millions of
dollars buying and searching for the
answer
yes yes
they're just going
now when I was a kid you joined the
[__] drawing contest remember you
drew a picture of a parrot and if you
won you won 500 and and no you didn't
win any money they sent you 500 in
edsels and they're different yeah
I trust me I drew that parrot a few
times that's why I became a comic you
know what I'm saying
it's great I I love learning I love
reading about somebody like I always
love [__] the
Spielberg book on writing you know I
think that's just just to hear the
Carrie Story yeah that all those books I
I and I would get jealous I would buy
those books read them and then [__] you
Stephen King
you [__] and it's just it's
writing you know what college did you go
to for writing I went to University of
Delaware so I yeah and I actually wanted
to be a New York Times journalist I want
to try for the New York Times so I was I
mean on the path that's what I really
wanted to do and it's funny because no
matter how hard you think
you're learning and excelling and how
hard the courses are and you think
you're growing my first job at a local
newspaper took me a year to be like I
can't even do local I could never do New
York Times I never thought about the
fact that I'd have to actually ask
people very difficult questions and I
don't have the personality to do that so
things like um I mean I should have
thought about this in college when I'm
so adamant on this New York Times uh
career path that
you know let's say somebody passed away
in the community tragically a teenager
they would send me to the parents house
to knock on the front door and get a
quote from the parents a day after the
child died and I I'm just my personality
I'm just not cut out for that there's
certain things that I can do but that
was just a no for me so I worked at that
newspaper for a year and at the year
mark I would come home crying and I'm
like I have to go stalk the brother of
this girl who just died who did not want
to speak with me and I get it now
looking back I'm like of course that's
part of being a reporter but I knew a
year in I'm like if I can't do this
there's no way I have no shot at the New
York Times literally no shot yeah I just
have no shot unless they're having me
right you know feature features on
something yeah uh so then I was like oh
maybe I'll write for magazines and at
the time magazines were starting to fold
too I mean they have some great online
magazines now but it's just not the same
as it used to be
so it's so funny
it's so funny that you were saying that
about uh
if I [__] forgot I gotta stop smoking
pot in the mornings
it's weird how
you think you want to do something this
is why we were just having this
conversation last night with some
parents so this gentleman was telling me
how he's really fearful about his
daughter going you know that kid's a
little older and he goes Joey my biggest
fear is college
how am I gonna do this four years I got
two kids and they're two years apart I
don't know he goes I make decent money
I'm a computer salesman all this [__]
and we were talking about the do you
really need college anymore
do you really need car and I I've always
stuck to my thing I tried to take
classes at Glassboro you know for money
and I quit I just couldn't cut it and
then on my own pace I found myself back
to Colorado Mountain College and I was
doing okay again
and that's because I took that year off
I really took that year off and I I
still believe it's such a hard sell It's
A Hard Sell I'm gonna have to have a
hard sell with Mercy but my proposal is
here's the dealers
you're not going to go to college
After High School you're going to take a
year off
I want you just to get a retail job I
don't give a [__] what it is makeup
books at Barnes and Noble Cars it
doesn't matter something where you have
to deal with the public for one year one
year
in that year I'll pay your car payment
I'll pay your rent your meals whatever
you earn it's all yours
one year just give me that for college
or whatever save save but don't save
yeah I'm not even looking for that I'm
looking for you to to realize what Erica
realized Erica grew up I can't wait to
be a New York Times writer there's
nothing wrong with that goal but you
didn't really plan it out nobody does
we're [__] 16. who the [__] are you
to put on my lap when I'm 18. that I
have to pick my career decision for life
yeah and this is the other mistake we
make also that we look at this and when
our children a lot of you are too young
for that and go what this is going to be
a hard sale for me this is a hard sale
for anybody how can I tell Paula you
know your cousin I don't go to college
you see no I want to be with my friends
dad you know I want to go I want to go
to college they go to University of
Delaware we're all on the same
fraternity but I know for a fact if she
takes that year off
and just deals with people get to know
their people are liars people come in
and go oh Erica I'm definitely going to
buy that car I'll be back at three and
also you're outside drinking coffee you
see him pulling out of a Volkswagen like
people that you [__] you and you're like
what happened people Liars yeah people
are [__] Liars oh they ran into a
Salesman you follow me or they ran into
a Salesman you thought you would be this
Talisman by being very nice and I
realized that
I can never be a journalist with this
podcast
we used to do a lot more guests on the
church there's one guest I'm thinking
about in particular he came on and there
was some friction in his life I'm not
the type of person to go
by the way talk to me about this
situation
to turn this into because I always
wanted a podcast I'm not doing 60
minutes yeah you follow me that's where
you use that type of love people already
know that but not really because when I
did that podcast people hit me up for
weeks ago we didn't like that you didn't
bring that topic up with them and I was
like a podcast for me is a happy place
yeah I don't want a podcast to argue
with people I don't want this to start
arguments with other podcasts that's not
what I do this
there's enough of that [__] going on I
just want to crack jokes and smoke dope
and see your friend you know yeah but I
always thought that that was brutal
about me having to go like dig a little
deeper in yeah like confront people I
could do it on the street
I don't want to create that moment of
you know saying unless you tell me
before the podcast bring it up because I
want to talk about that yeah that's how
I wanted
I always think yeah I just my
personality outside of work is very um
I'll ask people questions I'm very
strong personality but when it came to
doing things like that I just couldn't
do it but it's funny how you're saying
you wanted to do the positive end of the
conversation and that's why I ended up
switching into public relations and
internal Communications because it was
all writing but it was the positive end
of it so if you're looking at an issue
PR's the entire purpose is to figure out
what's the good about this situation and
let everybody know versus somebody just
died let's go to ask their family about
it or looking into the more negative
aspects I just I felt better about what
the work I was doing
and it's I mean it was sad I used to go
into New York City and take take
pictures in front of New York Times just
you know
like I bring my friends like we had to
walk in front of the New York Times and
we'd have our little cameras and take
pictures and it's embarrassing you know
but I would that was my dream and then
it just took one year to realize it's
really crazy we couldn't be able to do
that it's really crazy while we're on
the topic what the business of news is
hmm yeah yeah people people want to hear
about you know oh my God uh Michael
Klein is getting married to Cynthia the
Philadelphia clients yeah yeah that's
great you know how many newspapers will
that sell though the people will get
married their families want to buy the
newspaper you know I think about Don
Henley's song Dirty Laundry when he was
saying that get the Widow on the set we
need dirty laundry you know
you know what is the news what has the
news become and what is the [__] news
somewhere that we go to get information
of what's going on but you really think
about it the news has become
they're telling they're telling you what
that you want so 247 and WPIX what's the
first 15 minutes of the news a kid
burned to death in Harlem a baby died in
the house fire three people have been
displaced by a fire it's all bad [__]
news so you look at the news and go what
the [__] is this right yeah and then we
have the pay channels like your cnns and
your Fox and all those and I'm not
politically inclined but I know that
each one represents a different that
Democrats over there Don lemon's a
[__] hypocrite he's a liberal he's
this and they're all doing the same
thing bashing Trump right to get the
most viewers like it's it's just really
crazy what the business of the news is
and how either you're a news person to
me I don't want to wake up to the news
no ever again ever again
ever again yeah as I'm eating my cereal
my Captain Crunch or whatever the [__]
makes me happy what's the cereal that
pop in the morning
yeah
you're listening I don't want to hear
about the three kids at birth to death
at seven in the morning before I have to
leave my [__] house so that's why I
don't watch the news right but look at
what the news has become like and
sometimes you watch do you ever been in
the dentist office and you're like come
back in two minutes we're going to show
you a spring casserole and you're like
you know what
I'm at the dentist office right now and
even if I was home I wouldn't want to
see a spring casserole on the news but
then you're like wait a second
if they're going to tell me a spring
casserole and the three black kids that
birthed the dent in the Bronx yeah I'd
rather get the springtime casserole yeah
spring casserole so true yeah I used to
because I was so I mean I even went to a
high school for communications because I
was already convinced then that I wanted
to be a reporter
um and I would have newspaper
subscriptions and I would read the news
I mean this is so nerdy but I really did
it I would read the news I was so
obsessed with knowing what was going on
all the time
currently I I mean I have what could be
described sometimes as crippling anxiety
that's the last thing I need to see to
your point in the morning I don't need
to set my day into anxiety written that
I'm gonna I don't know gonna get shot in
my Supermarket like I don't want to have
to think about that it's not that I
block it all out but I really limit my
news consumption
to and I try to keep it to just
celebrity stuff it's fun I don't have to
get stressed about it these celebrity
stuff yeah and look at it I go what's
the I don't know if I want to hear news
about something I want to hear news
about the world Happy stuff you know I
used to make fun of that you know
Eyewitness News what's the one that we
watch at 6 30. but all the older people
watching
um uh yeah no no no ABC World News
reports oh yes I used to watch that too
the pandemic destroyed me that that
destroyed me and I used to always make
fun of it and go I gotta wait till the
last 15 seconds where they show you the
blind kid that plays Beethoven to make
you happy like this is one kid playing
Beethoven you're like oh my God you're
like okay we're back but it's true
you just tortured me for 28 minutes bad
news how we're gonna get the worst snow
report this year the the stock market's
gonna go down interest rates are going
up now you're gonna go oh
now we're going to show you a happy
story from Iowa yeah who plays ping pong
well and then you know yeah
[Laughter]
it's [__] crazy man so when after the
newspaper stuff what was your next
uh yeah so then I like I said I was like
you know what public relations is the
total opposite of what I was currently
doing so I started looking into it and I
got a um really lucky to get a
fellowship with Johnson and Johnson and
Rutgers and Johnson Johnson brought me
into their Communications team and I was
doing PR in comms and I was just writing
all day and it was the best so I was
like all right here we go here's a
career that I can you know be into it's
good stuff every day it's fun I still
get to interview people but it's not I'm
not looking for negative answers I'm
actually looking for what's going on
that's great in their life and from
there I did that for quite a while I've
worked in uh different PR agencies in
the city and it was awesome I really
loved it I just at a certain point
Corporate America after 10 years of it I
was just
especially when you're a writer hold on
one second I'm gonna break the
commercial break and then we'll come
back and we'll finish this up and now
for a word from our sponsors [__]
thank you for taking a minute from The
Joint listen Uncle Joy's joint is
brought to you by DraftKings today it's
NBA playoff time getting on the big hoop
action with DraftKings Sportsbook an
official sports betting part of the NBA
Lucas
you got to place a five dollar pregame
moneyline bet and if you score you're
gonna get 150 and bonus bets when your
team wins who's better than you nobody
plus everyone could score with the no
sweat no game parlay every day during
the NBA Playoffs just open the
DraftKings Sportsbook app opt-in and
place the same game parlay on any NBA
game for ten dollars if it doesn't hit
you'll get a bonus bet back up to ten
dollars so do me a favor it starts with
you it's NBA we got UFC and we got Major
League Baseball download the Sportsbook
app today sign up with code Joey new
customers you're gonna get just put five
dollars on a pregame moneyline bet and
if you score you get 150 in bonus bets
who's better than you DraftKings do me a
favor if you got a gambling problem
called 1-800 Gambler in Massachusetts
call 1-800-3
327 50 50. in New York call 8778 Hope
New York eligibility restrictions apply
see DraftKings slash sports book for
details and state specific responsible
gambling resources thank you for all
that the bottom line is download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app
bet five dollars on a money line bet and
get 150 in bonus bets when your team
wins stay black code Joey
we're back [__] anyway now back to
now back to the thing people want to
hear and it's very interesting how we
got together yeah yeah
it's funny because like I said to you I
was struggling a lot with the book I
have a great book agent his name is
Gordon and the thing I liked about him
the most was his patience yeah you know
he was very patient with me anybody else
that I had spoken to about writing a
book they were always very go go he just
kept telling me just write a sentence a
week
write a sentence a week and I felt like
I was uh this relationship isn't going
nowhere
you know when you have an agent uh for
theatrical you know you have to go on an
audition when you have an agent for
comedy you have to go do these things
with this book I didn't know I didn't
even know where to start I'm not a
writer so I didn't know you know I have
I had aspirations of things I think I
could do if I could write for a magazine
get Sports Illustrated on the phone you
know you're an idiot so when I moved
here I was frustrated you know with the
book
I kept putting it away I think the last
girl I was working with
that's the one that lived in San Diego
and would come up on Thursdays or
something and I kept telling like listen
let's just do this for like a week
straight you have to keep coming up
because you're not gonna lie to me dog
it's rough driving
it's rough driving when there's no money
I would give him money for gas and stuff
and I try to be you know taking a lunch
when she'd come up but after like six
weeks she just stopped I stopped paying
for her she changed the numbers she
would come to the house and hang out
with me and mercy and it just went out
the window one day and she kept
everything she worked on yeah I think
she sent it to Terry or something she
goes I got a movie or something that was
it nobody wanted to go the full distance
yeah you know once that everybody could
do it but once they saw the meat and
potatoes they couldn't go to fall
distance
two years later I moved to New Jersey
and I'm at a family reunion with the
Florentine crime family who has many
different weapons like I've told you
guys for years they have different
weapons
and one of the weapons is they have a
writer that's a niece someone started
talking and
at first I'm like she's too sweet for me
to tell these stories like this is not
gonna [__] work she comes from great
stock her mom and dad are sweethearts I
mean this might not work but I was like
wait a second
our [__] uncles are crazy
Uncle Jim told the story on this podcast
about the wrestler the wrestling
photographer that yes Grandpa was
friends with them yeah they brought him
over and he tried to molest Jimmy in the
middle of the night yeah should we woke
up in the middle of night and this fly
was open the guy's like hold up I'll
make it better I got these wrestling
pictures you can have them for free and
then Jimmy's like okay but Jimmy told
his Uncle Bob and uh Joe yeah your dad
and they went and beat the wrestler up
and they dropped them off on the way up
to nine that bus station right there
because he still remembers them hitting
them with the with the [__]
newspapers from the boxer you take the
corner and I'm like if she could listen
to that story yeah she could hear some
of my stories we're okay here so it was
like we started talking and
I tell the thing I remember the most is
coming back from surgery
and being [__] going to uh PT and
they'd be twisting my knee and [__] and
finally the guy would say to me I don't
know if are you taking pain medication
before you come here and I'm like no and
he's like you should we're twisting in
there no matter no wonder you're [__]
yelling and screaming so I would take
the pain pill before I went to the PT
and then I would come here a half hour
later an hour and a half later and I'd
be
[__]
up
[__] up on those oxycodons whatever
the [__] they give you and I remember
being on the phone with her in between
my gums being uh swollen and the pills I
couldn't speak
I'd be like [__] slurring I'm like
how's this girl
catching all this [__] info
yeah I record I would record them and I
would take notes and then transcribe
them as kind of my process when I'm
doing books with people
um and I never even noticed you know
like I didn't even know that was going
on and at the same time which I'm always
so grateful for this book in particular
and I've told you this because when we
started working on this I was going
through a really difficult time
personally and I just
needed something funny and positive as a
project and it came at the exact right
time I think it was like a month into me
going through a pretty bad time you had
called me and I well first of all I was
freaking out because I I mean so many
people are fans of yours obviously and I
have so many friends who are obsessed
with you they cannot believe it I was
playing your voicemail when you called
to ask if I would write the book to my
friends and everyone's screaming uh so
we were all super pumped obviously I was
too but every day even if I was having a
really really bad day I knew you and I
would talk and we would talk about some
funny story from your childhood
and I would just it would change my day
around because it's different right like
if I'm writing
a book for somebody and it's about
financial planning let's say you know
going through a tough time personally
and writing a financial planning book
there's no change in mood right I'm just
writing their book
still feeling kind of cranky but with
yours it was like Not only would I get
to hear the story and crack up then I
would play it again because we had it
recorded and I would go through the
transcripts and I'm writing and still
laughing it just it brought me a really
good like sense of joy in a time that I
really needed it so
and for me the process was
first off I I was withdrawing on the
Xanax so my body was not well my anxiety
level was not well I couldn't focus it
was like a beginning of depression I
couldn't make eye contact
you know I still tell people I remember
my best friend in the world coming here
and I went to eat lunch and I couldn't
wait for him to leave I
you gotta go yeah I can't do this I
can't make eye contact I don't want to
hear what you're saying Ari
Ari one of my brothers I just couldn't
have him around I was like when Mike
would come up we just did the podcast
like you gotta go like I just could not
so I still remember and I don't want to
admit this in public but I have to
because I like to tell all my [__]
dirty secrets there were days where
you know I until two weeks ago when I
did the audio book I didn't know what
the first couple chapters were about
I was so done with anxiety that would
get off the phone and go
what did I just tell Erica I hope I told
her something pretty [__] good
between the pain pills and what I was
going through and the weed and
there was something I didn't know but my
process for the book was
I would sit here for two or three nights
and just make notes and then put them
all together
and it was good for me at the time from
what I was going through it was scaring
me too because this all happened in
Jersey
so I'm like holy [__] I forgot about
this what if these people come looking
for me now bro I still remember going
out at night and smoking pot and going
am I gonna get [__] shot when I'm out
here is there going to be somebody out
there like that's how insane the stories
were the Gabby story and then it started
but we always then it got to a point
where we were telling stories with a
huge payoff at the end like a laughing
or like we couldn't believe it happened
or something and that was overwhelming
that was really overwhelming to go wow
that story here for years I thought that
was a shitty story but look how it ended
the ending makes up
for what happened so it was a [__]
great process for me for what I was
going through yeah it was making me
remember
you know it was making me it was it was
holding me accountable for the first
time and I had nothing going on I wasn't
doing stand up like I I told Vinnie's at
dinos and Uncle Vinnie's I can't even
focus on stand up let me just do this
[__] book so it was like it was
perfect for us it was like two people
meeting at the same time I didn't
realize that until I actually read the
book I did the audio book yeah I didn't
remember what I said on that book I had
no [__] idea it was it two years ago
it was a long time ago yeah so for a
year and a half yeah I've been excited
about the book like we were saying no we
wrote the book now we gotta wait because
yeah we handled it in
2022. we handed the book in January
2022. yeah
so like March last year I was already
like
I might as well get a copy of that book
because I really don't know
what I was saying out there you know I
don't know if we went off the deep end
if I told like craziest stories and when
I got the audio version I was like okay
yeah this is everything I wanted to be
in it I gotta be honest with you it's
got everything I wanted there's a few
stories that I think we cut out because
they're already on YouTube or something
like that yeah but it's got everything
in there yeah and there were a couple of
things I think through the editing
process with the editor that they said
maybe don't include this part I know
there were some legal things right
um stuff like that but I I agree I think
any story Gabby is a great example any
story they're like oh you know that was
kind of going bad it closes up nice it's
kind of
yeah we'll say we'll say no well the
Gabby story ended up with him
threatening to kill me next time he saw
him yeah and then you're out and then
I'm out yeah and then I never saw him
again and then maybe seven years ago my
ex-family doctor called me we would talk
and he goes I bumped into your godfather
and now it's like how did it really end
you know he's dead and I miss him lately
like I went to the movies with my
daughter Monday because there was no
school last week
while we were at the movies because we
used to take me to the movies all the
time yeah I was telling like oh you know
I I took her to see air
and that's kind of an adult movie you
know for a child yeah and in the middle
of the movie she's like that was Michael
Jordan at yeah you know Michael Jordan's
not gonna shoot I I why we come here
four you know
and I was like you know Mercy is a story
about air and whatever but on the way
home I said to her
when I was your age I had somebody who
took me to the movies and I remember how
powerful it was yeah you know so Gabby
lives in my heart still today and I told
her about Gabby how he would pick me up
I didn't tell him about the briefer and
the [__] guns and the the best when
he took me to see a live sex show oh I
didn't even know that he knew like I did
not know like three Spanish chicks and
we went to an apartment it wasn't like
at a club it was like an apartment in
Manhattan a nice apartment a Midtown
Manhattan I walked in this pre-chicks
eating each other out in 60 90. and he
smoking pot giggling and I'm like six
playing with my G.I Jones
my whole life was awkward at that age
okay
[Music]
dog I don't want to see that [__] be
beating each other out I don't even know
what she was eating
it for what is that that's not good
and that was the other thing that you
could handle a lot of those stories
because that that I also found was very
rough on people when you have to tell
the honest like I wasn't trying to make
myself good in this store in this book
yeah I never been trying I never tried
to listen to kidnapping you can't ever
make good it's funny we giggle about it
you know last night somebody sent me uh
a Club Nouveau album Club Nouveau is
this band it's Timex
look at all these rumors and take it no
more it was like the early Timex
whatever Club yeah Club Nouveau was uh
an album a band and they had one
particular song For the Love of Francis
and I was dying this morning when I saw
the album cover because it was my
in prison it was Domino night music like
you know like who could even say that
they went to poker night in prison
how funny that is like that song reminds
me of domino night
people like the Domino night what the
[__] is
oh I never even been to a domino night
that was on a regular day never mind in
prison like on Tuesday nights with
Domino night Thursday was movie night
and Saturday was poking in the daytime
but they both called the poker night but
who the [__] goes to Domino night on
Tuesday nights and they would be sitting
there doing uh there was that song they
only had like three cassettes so you
know it's jail it's not like you have DJ
[__] Willie up there slamming the 60s
and 70s they had three songs they had
Bobby Brown's new album which is My
Prerogative and then there's another
song on there uh
I give you Fancy Shoes whatever Don't Be
Cruel I will be on that talk and they
would slam The Dominoes to the beat like
hold on hold on they would slam The
Dominoes to the beat and then sing to
each other I will be that cruel to you
and it was Domino night you know that
would [__] go there and just die with
the music who can live their life and
say that they went to Domino night in
prison
[Music]
you just can't tell this to people you
know like with the kidnapping if I look
at somebody and go listen I gotta tell
you something on top of this kidnapping
death for a minute after the kidnapping
occurred when I was getting out of there
I took my gun out and I took two steps
and I was gonna go in there and shoot
both people
I know for a fact if I'm a female
and I'm sitting with a gorilla like me
and some guy says that to me after he
goes okay we'll meet up tomorrow sure
sure we will you're gonna kill somebody
you were gonna [__] kill somebody now
you want me to meet you so I had all
these issues like going into this when
is Erica just going to hang up on me no
and you know what it's funny because I
it's it takes a lot for me to be shocked
and I say that because I started going
to Uncle Jim's shows when I was
five I don't know I'm curious I want to
ask my dad they used to bring me to all
the shows me and Joey and I mean we
would just I I'll always remember being
maybe sixth grade fifth grade something
like that we mentioned one of those
shows and Jim Norton is telling some
story about how he pays hookers to come
and [__] on a table glass table above
him and he lays underneath that and for
me as a little kid like I I could not
believe this but I still I wasn't even
really shocked I was just like I can't
wait to tell everybody like I went back
to school and I told all the guys the
you know my classmates wait wait until
you guys get older this is stinky stuff
you guys are gonna have to deal with I
thought maybe every guy's gonna like
that so I you know we would hear these
stories and then I would just go back
and tell people at school but nothing
really ever shocked me and uh I it would
take a lot for me to hear a story that I
would be very offended by
a lot I could tell yeah a lot
it would take a lot it's
do you see that
a hard time
be a hard time to tell
you it took me 30 years to tell like I
would tell Rogan or somebody Ralphie May
or
comic I was on the road with we'd be
telling I'd tell him a North Bergen
story but I would always like go back to
my room like
I don't know if I should have told them
that you know so then when I started
saying them on the podcast
the [__] funniest thing happened this
week
I saw an old day night when people get
old memories yeah I never saw this
before in my life
a friend of mine hit me a message on
Facebook and he goes hey man did you see
that kid that reviewed your podcast and
I didn't know what that meant I didn't
see it when he sent me the thing he just
said did you see it later on in the
afternoon
on Facebook I saw an old church thing
with me sitting like this and it was
from 2014 and it said under it
growing up in Secaucus New Jersey
people always told me that people from
North Bergen were kind of crazy and to
stay out of there
to listen to three episodes of this
podcast I will agree that people from
North berg are going to basically
[__] animals
he wrote that and you see a bunch of
people my friends growing up yeah tell
them to go [__] themselves [__] you with
Secaucus it's a [__] pig farm you
know yeah and it's like
all those little things always made me
ashamed like I was like
but
after I read this book as a whole I'm
like
no matter what happened in my life no
matter what happened prison whatever one
thing you can't deny is I got my money's
worth
yeah
these words
made me feel ever since I've read this
book and I've looked at it from that
perspective it's really changed me in a
way like you know what I was feeling
really bad about myself for years never
mind the comedy and I still feel bad
about the daughter's [__] and the losing
my parents if I told you no I'd be lying
to you yeah but that whole thing after
reading that took me like four days to
summarize and go on
you know I got a friend that thinks he's
[__] Johnny successful
and the truth of the matter is he lived
in his mother's house when he was 40 and
then one day when he decided to grow up
at 42 he bought a house two doors down
from his mother you know
and with tight I love him to death but
what a sad life
that he never left the block
I'm not being funny about this I'm not
trying to be cute I just want you to
really think about this this guy worked
hard his whole life
and never left the block
and he had moms and he had a dad and he
had uncles and cousins and nieces and
nephews and here I had none of that but
I had a full [__] life I got my
money's worth some of it wasn't to be
proud of getting arrested is not to be
proud of but I tell you what's made me
happy chasing James Coburn
with Joe Rogan in the [__] car on
Sunset Boulevard when he was an Acura
NSX we saw James Cobra to the light me
and Joe Rogan with like two young kids
it's 98. I'm like Rogan tell me that's
not James Coburn you better [__]
follow him I can't drive that fast you
better stay on them and we're chasing
this guy who does that
who could say they have a Chase James
Coburn down because they were that
[__] a bunch of it's like it's like
you saying to me dog you're not gonna
believe this when Nirvana came to Philly
I chased Kurt Cobain for an hour in the
comment you're like who does that you
had a full life brother
people don't even think of doing that
and that's what it made me realize that
what a shitty way to find out that your
life wasn't that bad after all
and that's why a great friend of mine
told me it's a great man I think
everybody should do this
write about your life one time
you're going to be really surprised what
you learn like right I'll never forget
getting to L.A and talking to this guy
and I'm going first thing you should do
is write your life
everybody right your life so you can
really see what you didn't do and what
you did do and you'll put a tag on it
whatever feelings I had I used to be
ashamed about being Mercy's father
that she's going to have to live with
the things I did
and again I'll tell us someday guess
what I did do I got my money's worth out
of this [__] I got left back I
went to prison you know I got an ingrown
toenail you know I got my money's worth
[__] you know so that's the
biggest thing I think that I gotten from
this book and I you said this from early
on it's a Redemption story every even
the little stories well I love those
little funny things even just you
running through the mall with them
people will see this in the book but
going through the mall with the Bruce
Springsteen uh the record records and
throwing them in a cop chasing you I
mean there's just like so many funny
things I don't want to give away too
much about that story because it's
really good but there's these are just
tiny pieces of the book and
to me that would be like the standout
thing I did in my life but like that was
just one of your stories and it doesn't
like it's not even bad it's just so
funny and I think I mean there are so
many laughs in this book so many and you
know I by the third part of it the
comedy part really start to see someone
who yeah it's just turned his life isn't
funny yes it's not yeah
you're still working it's it's it's been
[__] it's crazy yeah I think the the
story that got me from the book was and
I tell this on the podcast people know
that when I smoke crack with the when I
smoke the angel dust with the pregnant
chick yeah you know come on man every
time I think of that story even today I
go come on
[Music]
man that is [__] crazy what do you
want to see happen for this book for I'm
really proud of you
I hope the world opens up for you Erica
I really hope that
you know I think I got another book in
me yeah maybe in three months we'll
start hashing it out I would love to do
that I see a lot of great things
happening before you get a really great
job on this book
I'm happy I got to get it out there I
mean
I I'm grateful to you thank you of
course and I think I mean it's just when
people do a memoir
it's just a Really Brave thing to do
like you put your heart and soul into
all of this putting the notes together
working with me your willingness to
share this with so many people because
it's a lot and I mean people I always
think I would love to write my own
Memoir one day I just don't even know it
takes bravery to really put your stuff
out there so kudos to you for that I
would say for me with ghost writing
Memoirs are just my thing like I just
I've written self-help books I've
mentioned I've done financial planning
I've done business books but Memoirs are
just what I love to do all I would go
straight Memoirs for the rest of my life
I find it amazing I find it fun it's
work that I wake up and want to do every
day so
can't beat it I feel like I finally
found a profession that I'm like this is
it this is exactly what I want to be
doing and a lot of people don't get that
so it's an opportunity to be creative
yeah people don't get what they really
want doing yeah so that's the number one
thing scratching a surface to know what
to it's like what you said you grow up
thinking I want to be a cop
can't wait my mother was a cop my father
was a cop my grandfather was a cop
everybody was a guy my Tony my Uncle
Tony before he went to prison he was a
cop you know everybody was [__] yeah
yeah and one day you get up and you're
like
I wanted to help people
I didn't want to arrest people yes yes
yes like that's exactly what it is I
didn't want to help people I didn't want
to rush back I didn't want to help
people I wanted to arrest people okay
you're a cop now but it's just maybe you
should have been a social worker it's
it's nailing down and that is so [__]
hard and I feel the same way that
there's no way I could have done
anything else except for stand-up time I
don't
yeah yeah I'm worthless I'm like tits on
a ball but
you know it's it's it's uh yes
it's uh it just works out so I'm really
happy that you got a part of me in my
dream and I got to be a part of your
dream yeah here we are it was the best
I've the I I just I keep going back to
this but what a perfect time for that
book to come into my life into your life
we just had those few months that we
were initially working on it it just
helped me get from kind of a dark place
to starting to feel like myself again
and uh I'm very appreciative how can
people find you Erica florentine.com
really yeah Erica florentine.com has
some info on some of the writing things
that I'm working on now and uh how to
work with me in the future like I said
I'm I'm really interested in doing more
Memoirs that would be if I could just go
straight memoirs
that would be the most ideal Life For Me
fun happy my true calling I think so
I'm very proud of you thank you I love
you all my heart I love you I can't wait
for a little party I'll Cinco de Mayo I
know it's going are you so much yeah
Cinco de Mayo thing and uh hopefully
we'll get Mike up if he can make it up
on a Friday night
huh
what is Rudy's shuttle I thought it was
like that weekend we got to figure it
out like the eighth like the seventh or
something oh okay yeah this is a Friday
night so I don't think it's a Friday
night I think this is more of a
[Music]
thank you thanks for having me anytime
this is a [__] my pleasure I love you
[__] with all my heart thank
you for being part of the joint on
Monday the 17th happy have a great and
happy 4 20. and remember I'm telling you
this right now I got a gift for you
[__] on 420. it's a surprise
get ready to rock I love yous and now
for a word for my [__] sponsors
all right I want to thank Erica
Florentine at Erica florentine.com and I
want to thank you guys for the support
for always having my back the joint is
brought to you by listen guys it's 4 20
week it's time to smoke to your [__]
toenails turn purple get ready to smoke
with the freeze pipe the best
you smoke with no throat burn for the
coldest smoothest [__] hit from a
freezable pipe bubble or bung with
freeze bite the secret is the glycerin
chamber pop that baby in the freezer for
an hour and watch as your smoke is
cooled by a 300 degrees you know me guys
I like all their [__] buns but this
new tornado oh my god listen this is
your opportunity to go to freeze pipe
thefreeze pipe.com for the biggest sale
of the year and I'm not [__] around
and what I'm going to do is this either
you take the Joey the Diaz code at 10
off or you get your own pipe with with
discounts are up to 40 on so like pipes
bubblers bongs and more so visit
thefreeze pipe.com and find your
favorite piece you follow me use
something like you like I don't know if
you want something that's on sale you
got that if you want to use the dope the
Diaz code to get 10 off your entire
order go there but remember that's
thefreeze pipe.com use code Diaz for 10
off or shop the 420 sale and it ends for
20. the joint is also brought to you by
liquid IV listen Festival season is
coming filthy people with herpes jumping
up and down stinking the booze and God
knows what else if they breathe on your
neck you're gonna need to refuel that's
what liquid IV has you covered one stick
in that desert you get five essential
vitamins and two times faster hydration
then water alone when you're thirsty for
more than ecstasy and MDMA you're
[__] taken you even if he has three
times the electrolytes of traditional
sports drinks that comes in 12 flavors
like strawberry lemonade seed Berry is
[__] tremendous in the Pina Colada oh
my God you think you're hanging out with
[__] Jimmy Buffett anyway my personal
favorite come on now is the cherry and
the concord grape is [__] tremendous
liquid IV has five essential vitamins
B3 B5 B6 B12 and vitamin C they got all
the bees covered it's also non-GMO and
gluten dairy and soy free who's better
than you liquid IV listen you get your
liquid IV in bulk nationwide at Costco
or you get 20 off when you go to liquid
iv.com use code Joey at checkout that's
liquid iv.com use code Joey and Checker
and that's 20 off anything you order
when you shop better hydration today use
promo code Joey at liquid iv.com I want
to thank liquid IV
I want to thank DraftKings and I want to
thank the freeze pipe on this beautiful
glorious week and you [__] have
a great week stay black and I love you
I'll see you next Sunday Monday whatever
the [__] Tip Top Magoo
foreign
[Music]